how would you i know how you feel gail
you'd like to work only for what is the
question the question is how would you
the viewer like to work fewer hours but
for the same amount of money is that a
trick question
[Laughter]
come on
yep that's the reality for a growing
number of american workers california
lawmakers are considering a bill to make
the standard work week 32 hours instead
of 40. if it becomes law it would apply
to workers and companies with 500 or
more employees
many private
businesses across the country already
trying a four-day work week hoping to
reduce stress without reducing
productivity chris van cleave went to
colorado to see how one of them is doing
it
when emily lutchens started at uncharted
in 2020 the denver-based non-profit was
running an experiment could they
maintain 100 productivity and pay while
working 20 less it's an opportunity to
take a step back and think about
how you can be smarter with your work
are you happier working four days a week
instead of five
i'm definitely happier
and i think that
i'm just living my life better
nationally 92 percent of employees favor
a four-day work week but ceo banks
benitez wanted to know his business
wouldn't suffer so he brought in an
analyst to track productivity and the
impact of a four-day week on employees
how has that changed how you guys do
business it's changed everything i mean
it reduced workplace stress
reduced burnout we saw no reduction in
productivity and every friday was off
henry ford's assembly line ushered in
the standard five-day work week in 1926
and while that remains the norm today's
workforce is demanding better life
balance a trend sped up by the pandemic
in iceland roughly 85 percent of the
country works or will soon work four
days a week earlier this year belgium
announced employees can opt to work for
10 hour workdays and across north
america and the uk dozens of companies
including crowdfunding site kickstarter
are testing a four day week can the
four-day work week work for everyone oh
that's unlikely
to work for everyone bill shannon from
consulting for mckinsey and company the
challenge is
for the portion of the workforce that
has gotten a taste of flexibility
flexibility
full stop
is way more attractive than still the
mandate but on a shorter number of days
california congressman mark takano has
introduced legislation to make workers
eligible for overtime after 32 hours
instead of 40. it's time to re-examine
you know what the work week should look
like in the 21st century at uncharted
the new norm means prioritizing what's
important so we're really thoughtful
about what is the most essential work
that we're doing
is this meeting really critical for us
to have can we cancel this meeting
you're canceling meetings any given work
week we will cancel
10 of the meetings 15 of the meetings
because we don't need them they're not
essential or we just shorten them are
you hiring
for emily lutchens the extra time is
making balancing her career with being a
new mom a little easier could you see
yourself ever going back to a job that
was monday through friday um
[Laughter]
it would be hard working smarter
to get more time for herself
for cbs mornings i'm chris van cleeve in
denver
oh i hope this is a trend that catches
on tony
jobs it's kind of a no-brainer you know
you got all this technology you can get
a lot more done in a shorter amount of
time and people want it like i said
in 2000 when france made it a 35-hour
work week there were some people who
were able to take advantage of that not
everybody there were still people
working 40 hours 45 hours if the job
demanded it but the option was there but
you could do 40 hours in four in four
days and you can work four long days and
still have all that time to relax and
repeat i mean you know people keep
smirking when they talk about this but
it's serious and it can really help a
lot of folks and as long as you get the
work done i don't know what the issue is
i think it's harder for us in these jobs
yeah there's certain jobs you can use
yeah there's certain jobs you can't yeah
we're still looking for a five-day week
in this job
are
we did you hear the sudden chill in the
room
iceberg
speaking on behalf of our producing
staff they think they'd love a five-day
week
that's right yeah yeah yeah all right
tax deadline days away
you're on the forefront of things but it
can be exhausting as well exactly